l'open de france 2010 être entre dans
une nouvelle ère le tournoi est passé
cette année sous le pavillon du groupe
d'investisseurs chinois à chennai
l'entreprise investit dans leur rendez
vous saint quentinois et la dotation est
passé à plus de 7 millions de dollars le
double par rapport à 2016 nous
sommes-nous fédération ravid cette
évolution nous sommes ravis de cette
montée en puissance de notre peine
nationale et puis on croise les doigts
pour ça se poursuit dans l'aude tous les
temps du terme
pour cette édition 2010 est la
compétition a tiré des têtes d'affiché
françaises comme alexander levy au
victor dubuisson et des stars
internationales comme jeune ram ou tommy
fleetwood sur le plan sportif le
rendez-vous également intégrer les rolex
series les meilleurs tournois européens
c'est un superbe événement voilà on a la
chance de faire partie des plus gros
tournois européens
donc pour nous français on est très
heureux d'avoir un tournoi comme ça il a
appris en dimension c'est déjà c'était
déjà un gros tournoi mais là c'est
encore plus gros je pense que c'est
vraiment voilà une des meilleures
éditions cons et qu'on ait eu à jouer au
niveau du décor les spectateurs ont pu
voir du changement nouveau parking
nouveau centre de presse rénovation de
l'hôtel les prémices d'une organisation
millimétrée pour la ryder cup qui se
déroulera sur l'albatros en septembre
c'est vrai qu'à une année de la ryder
cup ça nous permet de faire des tests en
grandeur nature
c'est vrai qu'en termes de volume
l'open de france n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec une ryder cup il faut
quasiment tout multiplié par dix mais en
tout cas ça nous permet de faire des
tests
le parcours s'est mis lui aussi aux
dimensions de la ryder cup après
quelques modifications 2016 les greens
sont aujourd'hui parfaitement terminé
pour pouvoir accueillir les meilleurs
joueurs du monde c'est une parcours très
bon spectateurs on peut on peut voyez on
peut voir tout ça c'est très bon le
parcours est magnifique
franchement il améliore il ya beaucoup
améliorée par la fois d'avant là rien à
dire il est vraiment superbe
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
dernière répétition générale sur l'open
de france nouvelle génération
quelques mois avant de recevoir près de
200000 spectateurs pour la ryder cup